[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Please help me
welcome Craig O'Rourke.
[CLAPPING]
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Thank you Paul.
Everybody hear me OK?
Great.
So I've written a book,
"Destination Perpetuity."
The premise of my book is to
introduce the reader to what
I believe to be true wealth.
So I want to start by talking
today about what wealth is.
Now, there's thousands of
people that work here at Google.
And if I had the opportunity
to ask every person what wealth
is, I'd get hundreds, if not
thousands of different answers.
But when I ask people
what wealth is I
notice most people
usually give me a number.
They'll say, well,
I'd feel wealthy
if I had a half a million
dollars, or a million dollars,
or $10 million.
My point is, most people think
of wealth in finite terms.
I don't think of
wealth that way.
I don't think of wealth
in a finite term,
because if you have $1
million or $10 million,
and if you live long
enough and well enough,
you won't have any money left.
Right?
You'll go through it.
I think of wealth as infinite.
Wealth, to me, is safe,
secure, dependable cash flow.
It's money you can count
on month after month,
year after year, and
decade after decade.
That's why I think investing in
income producing real estate is
by far the best
investment anybody can
make to create true wealth.
Now, why do I say that?
Because income producing
real estate, the nature of it
is a self funding
investment, which
makes it also a
self-sustaining investment,
thereby creating an investment
that is an annuity for life.
It's a stream of cash that
lasts forever, isn't it?
It's truly an infinite
amount of money.
So let me explain
what I mean by that.
But before I get
into that, I'm going
to tell you how I got
the idea for the book.
I was asked recently,
how did you think
of putting this book together?
Well, it came to me organically.
I'm a baby boomer, 57 years old.
And I noticed when I
was in my 20s, 30s,
and 40s conversations
with friends and coworkers
were very carefree things.
We'd talk about were
the best happy hour was,
going to play beach
volleyball, or rock climbing.
About the time I turned 50
those conversations started
to change.
They started talking about
knee replacements, Lipitor,
and social security solvency.
Now, out of all these
AARP related topics
the one that seemed to cause
the most anxiety among people
was the one you'd think
they'd get the most excited
about, the topic of retirement.
When I'd ask people how or
when they wanted to retire,
I'd get shrugs.
People would say, I'm
going to work till I die.
I had one friend.
When I asked her when
she was going to retire,
she simply started crying.
I thought, this is not good.
And I knew a better way.
I know a way to
build true wealth.
So I decided to share
it by writing this book.
Now, I've been fortunate.
My book has been
selling pretty well.
And it started
trending a little bit.
And so I've gotten
speaking engagements.
And I was recently up in the
Bay Area in San Francisco.
And I was speaking to a group
of real estate investors,
and at the end had a
question and answer period.
And this one woman
stood up, and she said,
I really enjoyed your talk.
And I'm going to buy your book.
And I might even try and
follow some of your ideas.
She said, but there
was one thing missing
in your presentation, and
I said, what was that?
And she said, you
didn't mention anything
about your qualifications.
And I said, what do you mean?
And she said, well, where
did you go to school?
What degrees in
finance do you have?
And I said, well, I don't
have any degrees in finance.
I've never studied finance.
And she said, well,
with all due respect,
why should we listen to you
about investing money if you
don't have any qualifications?
So I shared a story with her.
I told her that
I've had a front row
seat for almost 40 years
watching as a real estate
portfolio started with just a
conversation around my parents'
kitchen table, and
blossomed into a self
funding, self-sustaining
portfolio of income
producing real
estate that carried
my parents through their
retirement very comfortably.
Let me tell you how
that came to be.
My dad was a real estate broker.
I was the youngest of four boys.
And he was fairly successful.
He sold income
producing real estate.
And he was so
successful, he decided
to open his own
brokerage about the time
I was eight or nine years old.
Now, that caused a lot
of anxiety in my house,
because when you start a
business, it's expensive.
So any extra money that
was coming into the house
went right back in to
build the business.
So consequently,
there wasn't a lot
of money in our house
on a monthly basis.
And there certainly wasn't a lot
of savings in our house either.
Now, my mother was
most bothered by this.
She would sit once a
month at the kitchen table
and pay all the bills.
And about half way
through paying the bills
she'd always say the same
thing, which puzzled me.
She'd say, I'm tired
of this roller coaster.
Get me off this ride.
Of course, that was her
analogy for the fact
that my parents never quite
seemed to have enough money.
And I didn't
understand that analogy
about my dad's business
and the income we had.
But even at that early
age of eight or nine
I too had a gauge on
my dad's business.
My gauge was the dinner table.
You see, I knew if
we had spaghetti too
many nights in a row, my
dad didn't have any clients.
If we had spaghetti
with meat sauce,
I figured he got a listing.
If there was chicken on the
table, something was in escrow.
And if I came home
and smelled steak,
ah, contingencies have
been removed, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Now, it didn't matter to me.
I like chicken, steak,
and pasta all the same.
But it mattered to my mom.
It mattered a great
deal to my mom.
So I'll never forget the
night that this conversation
of retirement came.
My mom was cooking
dinner, stirring
yet another pot of spaghetti.
I was sitting there
doing my homework.
My dad came walking in.
And my mother, when my dad
opened the door and walked in,
my mother froze him in the
doorway with just a stare.
He knew something was up.
He just froze.
He said, what?
What did I do?
My mom said, completely
out of the blue,
what are you doing about
our financial future?
My dad was ill prepared
for this question.
He said, I work every day.
My mom said, so do
I. I got four kids.
I work every day too.
That wasn't the question.
She said the question
was, what are you
doing about our financial
future, our retirement?
My dad thought about
it for a minute.
And he was a real estate agent.
So he always had
an answer, right?
He finally said, I'm
going to work till I die.
My mom said, OK, that's fine.
You go ahead and do that.
You go ahead and
work till you die.
But what if you die first?
What about me, and
what about these kids?
Well, my dad agreed that that
was not a very good plan.
So that night after dinner
they sat at the kitchen table
and they talked about options.
Now, the obvious option
would be for them
to buy a piece of income
producing real estate.
After all, my dad was
a real estate broker.
He sold income
producing real estate.
He owned a real
estate brokerage.
But the problem was, he
didn't have enough money.
They had a very small
amount of money saved.
Not enough to buy a
piece of real estate,
because real estate's expensive.
So they went to
plan B. They decided
to talk to my dad's friend Don.
Now, Don and my dad had
been lifelong friends.
They had gone to
college together.
They had served in
the military together.
They'd raised their
family together.
We used to vacation with them.
We were so close that
my brothers and I
called him Uncle Don.
And the one thing I
remember most about Don
was everybody always said,
he's the smartest guy we know.
That was what everybody
said about Don.
So when I heard my
parents, I didn't
know what retirement
was, but when
I heard they were going to
talk to Uncle Don about it--
I knew this was causing
anxiety in the house--
I thought, problem solved.
They're going to talk to Don.
So a couple weeks went by.
My parents had that
appointment with Don.
I was very excited to find
out what Don had to say.
So after the appointment I
came running up to my dad.
I said, dad, dad,
dad, what did Don say?
What did Don say
about our retirement?
My dad just shook his head.
He said, son, we're
not going with Don.
I said, what do you mean?
He's the smartest guy we know.
We have to go with Don.
My dad, you could tell
he was a little anxious.
He said, son, this is not
for you to worry about.
He said, just know
this, Don wants
to invest our money
in the stock market,
and we don't like that idea.
Now, my parents had both been
children in the Depression.
So they knew firsthand how
devastating so much money
in the stock market can be.
And they weren't going
to take that risk.
So I said, well, what
are you going to do dad?
He said, don't
worry about it, son.
I'm going to invest our money.
Now, again, I knew my
dad was good at his job.
I knew he invested
money for other people.
So that was fine.
I went about my business.
But my dad had a
problem, didn't he?
My dad did not have enough
money for a piece of income
producing real estate.
So he took a page from
my mom's playbook.
He went to work the next day.
And he asked all of his friends
and his coworkers how and when
they were planning on retiring.
Some of them shrugged.
Some of them cried.
Some of them said they'd
work till they die.
My dad found a few
like minded friends.
And together they
pooled their money.
They formed a partnership.
And they bought
their first piece
of income producing real estate.
And a few years later
they bought another one.
And in a relatively
short amount of time
chicken and steak became
much more frequent
on our dinner table.
Our summer vacations,
camping in Big Bear,
became two weeks in
the Hawaiian Islands.
The plan was working.
The cash was flowing.
And after a few years
they were successful.
They had a portfolio of
cash positive properties,
generating income, and
building equity over time.
When they got to their desired
retirement age, they were set.
They retired.
They had a very
comfortable retirement.
They had 20 years of
worry free retirement.
They lived in beautiful
home, drove nice cars.
They traveled.
They had the good
life for 20 years.
Safe, secure,
dependable money they
could count on for 20 years.
And everything was good.
But life changes.
Doesn't it?
And in 1997 my dad's good
friend Don passed away.
This was a very sad
thing for my dad.
They were very close.
My parents were very upset.
So I decided to take
them to the service.
Driving home from the service
I said to my dad, you know dad?
You know what I remember
most about Uncle Don?
He said, what?
I said, everybody
always used to say he
was the smartest guy we knew.
And my dad laughed.
He goes, people
did say that, son.
I remember that.
And he said, but you know what,
when it came to investing,
your mother and I were smarter.
And I said, oh, I
remember that, Dad.
I remember you didn't
invest with Don
because he was going to put
your money in the stock market.
My dad said, that
was only part of it.
That was only part of the story.
He said, you were too young
for me to explain to you
what the real reason
we didn't invest.
And I said, what was it?
See, what my parents
didn't like was the fact
that Don's firm used actuaries.
Now, most of you
probably here know
what an actuary does when
they work for an insurance
firm like that.
What they do is they ask
you certain questions.
They say, do you drink?
Do you smoke?
Do you use recreational drugs?
Do you exercise?
Is there cancer or diabetes,
or any other ticking time bomb
in your family bloodline?
They take all this information,
and they compare it
to mortality
charts, because they
need to determine approximately
how long you're going to live.
They need to know
that information,
because they need to give
that to men and women
like Don who plan
for your finances,
because they need to figure
out approximately how
long your money needs to last.
My parents didn't like that.
My parents didn't
like the idea of being
told how long their
money would last
and how long they
were going to live.
So they went a different
route, didn't they?
They invested in real estate.
And it worked out
beautifully for them.
But why?
Why is real estate
a better investment?
Let's do a little side
by side comparison.
Now, remember, I don't have
any degrees in finance.
But this is just my view of
how any investment works.
I see all investments
as having four phases.
The first phase is the
initial investment.
You simply pick what
you're going to invest in.
And you create a
plan, don't you?
So it's certainly easier
to get in the stock market.
You can start with a
little bit of money.
You go to somebody like
Don, and you say, hey,
I want to invest in
the stock market.
And you decide your
level of risk tolerance,
and all these good things.
You lay out your plan.
I want to retire at this age.
And I want to have
this much money.
Great.
Similar in some
ways to real estate.
With real estate you still
have to devise a plan.
You have to figure out
when the building's going
to get paid off, or paid
down to a point where
it can generate enough cash
flow for you to retire off of.
But the harder part with real
estate is that down payment,
isn't it?
It takes a lot of money
to get into real estate.
So a lot of people shy
away from real estate
because of phase one, because
it takes a lot of money, right?
So phase one is
absolutely easier
to get into with the stock
market than real estate.
But what about the other phases?
Let's take a look at
phase two for a minute.
Phase two is the
continued funding phase.
This is a very important phase.
No matter what you
invest in, you're
probably going to have
to continually fund it.
Most people start with
a small amount of money
and a very aggressive
retirement plan.
Everyone wants to retire
as early as possible and as
wealthy as possible, don't we?
So if you go to a guy
like Don and you say,
hey, here's my money, let's
get going, Don's going to say,
thank you very much.
Glad you entrusted
me with your money.
And I'm going to do everything
I can to build your portfolio.
But I got to tell you, you
gave me a small amount of money
here, and an aggressive plan.
So you're going to
have to help out.
So Mr. and Mrs. Investor,
every month you're
going to write me a check.
Month after month,
year after year,
decade after
decade, the investor
is writing checks to
fund their own portfolio.
Don does his part.
The investor does their part.
And it works nicely.
That's called investor funding.
What about real estate?
Real estate also needs
to be funded, doesn't it.
You have a mortgage.
You have taxes.
You have insurance.
You have a property manager.
And you better put
some money away,
because that roof will
leak, and that carpet
will need to be changed.
So you better have
a rainy day fund.
It takes a lot of
money, doesn't it?
So that's real estate investing.
But here's the part I like
about real estate best.
Those dollars should
be coming not from you,
but from your tenants.
Month after month,
year after year,
decade after decade, that
investor funding should all
come from your tenants
pockets, not yours.
What about the fun part?
What about phase
three, distribution?
That's the really good part.
All right.
Fast forward.
You're 65, or whatever age
you decide to retire at.
Ring, ring, ring.
Pick up the phone.
It's Don.
He says, happy birthday.
Happy 65th birthday.
We made it.
You're fully funded.
Don't send me any more checks.
I'm going to send you checks.
And he does.
He starts sending you
checks month after month,
year after year,
decade after decade.
Those dollars are
flowing into you, right?
Same with real estate.
You've made a plan.
And your property has
been paid down or paid off
to the point where all
of those tenant dollars
are now funding your
investment, right?
So they both work pretty much
in phase three, the distribution
phase.
But phase four is
the most important.
Phase four is the
continued asset growth.
You see, with Don's
plan, what happens?
The asset itself, the stocks,
the bonds, the mutual funds,
whatever you've invested
in must be sold off.
It must be liquidated
every time you
are going to get some
type of disbursement.
So over time that
portfolio liquidates
until there's nothing left.
But that's not the
case with real estate.
You see, because real
estate is self-funding,
the self-funding
nature of real estate
creates a self-sustaining
investment, right?
Which provides distributions
from the excess cash flow.
And the real estate
itself is left
untouched to be able to
continually appreciate
in value over time.
You see, my parents didn't like
the idea of fixed parameters
of time and money.
What they wanted was
infinite cash flow.
And that's what they got.
They created an
annuity for life.
They had a stream of cash
that would last forever.
That's what income
producing real estate
can do for you if
you do it right.
And it's a really
good thing they
went that path, because
remember those actuaries?
They told my dad
he'd live to be 75.
He didn't listen.
My dad lived to be 83
years old, eight years
passed what the actuaries
had planned for.
He would have run out of
money at 75 years old.
But instead those eight years,
he wasn't stressed about money
or looking for a job.
My dad was living a
very comfortable life,
living in a beautiful home,
traveling, enjoying life.
And my mom?
They told my mom
she'd live to 78.
She also did not listen.
My mother lived to 98.
20 years beyond
what the actuaries
would have planned for.
20 years.
She would have run out of
money in 1997 at 78 years old.
You know what would
have happened?
She would have ended up on my
pull out sofa in my guest room.
But that's not what happened.
What happened instead was she
continued to live her life.
She lived in a beautiful home.
She drove a nice car.
She traveled.
She ate out.
She lived the good life.
My mother never
even thought twice
about spending every dime
in her checking account,
even as a widower in her 90s,
because she knew next month
there'd be more money.
She knew that because she had
almost 40 years of watching
a cash flow portfolio provide
money, month after month,
year after year,
decade after decade.
For nearly 40 years she
never worried about money.
And what happened to her
real estate portfolio
from 1997 when she would have
had run out of money with Don
to the year 2017
that she lived to?
It exploded, didn't it?
I don't have to
tell anybody here
what happened to Southern
California income
producing real estate
from 1997 to 2017.
It exploded.
The biggest change in
my mom's financial world
was she was worth
so much more money.
She wasn't broke.
Everything continued to grow.
And she continued to
have all the money
she needed to live off of.
Now, before my dad died my mom
was much healthier than him.
And he knew she was going
to live for a long time.
And so he came to me and
he said, you know son,
I want to make sure you take
care of your mom's portfolio.
And I said, I will dad.
I promise.
So after my dad passed
I went to my mom.
I said, mom, I got to tell you,
I made this promise to dad.
My mom said, oh,
don't worry about it.
She said I've got a good CPA.
I'll get a good accountant.
I'll take care of everything.
You got your own life.
You're too busy.
Don't worry about.
I said, no, I made
dad that promise.
And I'm going to take
care of everything.
So she said, OK, but
before you sign on to this
let me tell you what you're
getting yourself into.
I said, OK.
She said I've got
four properties.
I said I know that.
She said all four
of those checks
come in at different
times of the month.
I said, OK.
She goes, I want them deposited
the minute they come in.
I said, no problem.
I'll set it up on
automatic deposit.
She said, oh, no.
Not my money.
No.
You're going to
take it to the bank
and deposit it at my branch.
And I said, well, mom, I
don't mind depositing it.
But there's a branch
right by my house.
She said, oh, no.
No, no, no.
You'll go to my branch.
And you'll go to window
six and you'll see Maria.
[LAUGHTER]
I said, mom, OK.
Fine.
I'll go to your branch.
But there's an ATM.
I'm just going to use it.
She says, oh, no.
No.
I had a problem
with an ATM in 1983.
That's not happening.
You're going to my branch.
You're going to talk to Maria.
I said, mom, your branch
has incredibly long lines.
She goes, I know.
You should take a newspaper
and a cup of coffee.
I said, all right, but
what if I get there
and Maria's not there?
She said, then you'll
go back the next day.
So guess what I did
for four times a month?
I'd go to the bank.
And I got in the habit
of taking a newspaper
and taking a cup of coffee,
because there were the longest
lines I'd ever seen.
And this one particular day,
I always take the "USA Today."
And you're probably all
familiar with the format.
And they have the money section.
It's in green.
And they the little money
snapshot at the base, right?
This one particular day had a
very interesting little money
snapshot.
And it was the results of a poll
they'd done by money managers,
people like Don, men
and women like Don
that invest money for people.
And the poll asked
one simple question.
What drives your clients?
Is it greed or is it fear?
By an overwhelming 83% the
respondents answered fear.
It was fear that drove
people to invest.
And that's really smart,
because it is fearful to run out
of money, isn't it?
And as I was standing in this
line I looked around the bank.
And they had a series of
posters all encouraging people
to invest money with this bank.
And they were all based in fear.
And I thought, wow, this bank's
really ahead of the curve.
I'm reading "USA Today" now.
And they've already got
[INAUDIBLE] posters up.
And there was one
poster in particular
that really struck me.
And it was this
nice little couple.
They're probably 65, 70 years
old, sitting on a park bench,
having a little picnic.
And the caption reads, will
you outlive your money?
And I thought, wow, that's kind
of a scary thought, isn't it?
And down below it says,
contact us to find the answers.
And as I'm standing
in this line I'm
holding a check for
$6,000 in my hand.
And that check
represented the proceeds
from one of my mom's properties.
And those proceeds, those were
after the taxes were paid,
and after the
insurance was paid,
property [INAUDIBLE]..
That's what she brought
back from that one property
every month, $6,000.
I wanted to stand up and yell,
I got the answer right here.
This is the answer, income
producing real estate.
But as I was holding that
check I started thinking,
how did this check come to be?
And I remember exactly when
my dad bought that building.
I remember because
it was the same week
I got my driver's license.
It was 1976.
I was 16 years old.
And I was running around.
I got my driver's license!
So excited.
My dad was running around.
I bought a building!
And he would always tell the
story about this building.
He was very proud of it.
And the story he would tell
is, it was a listing of his.
And it was 1976.
The economy was not great.
Interest rates were rather high.
And this building in
this particular area
was really not a very good area.
People were steering
away from it.
So they weren't really
investing money into it.
But my dad really
believed in this building.
And so he'd advertised it.
And he got the owner
to do some work on it.
And back then, of course,
1976, nobody had computers.
So what real estate
agents had to do,
they had to pick up the phone.
And they had to
start calling people.
So my dad would call
everybody he knew,
and all the clients he knew,
all the agents he knew.
He did this for weeks,
and weeks, and weeks.
Finally, just no takers.
So we went back to the
seller, a guy named Bill.
And he said, Bill, I got to
tell you, I've tried everything.
I've adverted.
I've called.
There's no takers.
And Bill said, I've got
to sell this building.
And my dad said, I know.
I think you need to
reduce the price.
And Bill said, oh, no.
No.
We're not going to
reduce the price.
You told me it was
worth $110,000.
And my dad said,
well, I believe that.
But I can't convince
anybody else of that.
And he said, well, I'm
not reducing the price.
Think of something else.
So my dad thought about
it, and he said, well,
interest rates are
kind of high right now.
And lending's pretty
restrictive right now.
He said, you own the
building free and clear.
Bill said, that's right.
He said, would you consider
doing some owner finance?
He said, absolutely.
He said, would you be
really aggressive with it
and let somebody put 10% down?
Bill said, absolutely,
but I want my price.
So my dad said, OK.
So he got back that day to the
office, got back on the phone,
started calling people.
He called this one friend Jim.
Now, he'd sold lots
of real estate to Jim.
And he made Jim a lot of money.
And he called Jim
and said, Jim, Jim,
I got to tell you
about this building.
Jim said, Mike, you've called me
about that building five times.
I don't want to hear
about it anymore.
I don't want it.
Don't like that area.
He said, no.
You've got to listen to me.
And he told him
about the financing.
And he said, well, it does
sound like a good deal.
But Jim said, you know Mike,
I got to ask you a question.
If this building's such a good
deal, why don't you buy it?
And my dad said, I would
love to buy it, Jim,
but I don't have any money.
And he said, OK, you have
a commission don't you?
My dad said, yes.
He said, what's your commission?
He said, 5%.
He said, OK.
And what does he want
down on the building?
10%.
Jim said, OK, tell you
what, let's buy it together.
I'll put in 5%.
You roll your commission in.
So they did.
They bought that building.
They bought that building
in 1976 for $110,000.
They put $11,000
down, $5,500 each.
That was my dad's
commission he rolled in.
And as I'm standing
in this line,
holding this check for $6,000
I started thinking, wow,
what is the Return
On Investment,
the ROI on a $5,500 investment
that returned $6,000?
Well, it's over 100%, isn't it?
But I thought about it.
I thought, well,
that's not really
the right way to figure a
return on investment, is it?
Because in real estate we always
talk in annualized numbers,
don't we?
So if you want to look at
it as an annualized number
it's really $72,000 a year.
I thought, wow, that's amazing.
A $5,500 investment that
returns $72,000 a year.
So I was starting to
figure out the ROI,
and I thought, wait,
that's not right either.
That's not the right
way to figure it either.
Because you really have to look
at all the positive cash flow.
And the building's been
paid off for 20 years.
Now, I've been doing
the books that long,
so I happen to know it
hasn't been $6,000 a month.
But on average it
was $4,000 a month.
So if you look at $4,000 a
month, times 12 months, well,
that's $48,000 a year.
Multiply that by 20, you
have $960,000, don't you?
So a $5,500 investment
that returns $960,000
of positive cash flow?
So I started to figure
the ROI on that.
And I thought, wait, wait,
wait, that's not right either.
Because we also have to
consider the first 20 years.
Because, remember, this is a
self-funding, self-sustaining
investment.
And those tenant dollars,
remember that phase two
where the tenant dollars
come in to pay down?
Got to figure that too.
Those were dollars that
came in to pay this off.
Now, it wasn't $4,000
a month back then.
But you know what it was?
It was $2,000.
So if you look at that, $2,000
a month, times 240 months,
well, that's $480,000.
You add that to the $960,000,
you come up with $1,440,000.
I thought, OK, a
$5,500 investment
that returns $1,440,000.
What is the ROI on that?
And I start to figure that out.
And I said, wait a second.
That's not right either.
Because we're only talking about
the cash flow here, aren't we?
You see, real estate has
multiple streams of income.
There's also tax advantages.
There's 1031s.
There's write offs.
There's depreciations.
My head wants to
explode when I start
to think about that stuff.
I leave that for the CPA.
But let's talk
about the big dog.
What about appreciation?
That's where people really
make money in real estate.
It's appreciation, isn't it?
So this building that my
parents paid $110,000 for
is currently valued
at $2.7 million.
All right.
But remember, they had a
partner with this, didn't they?
So their value of the
building would be $1,350,000.
Now, if you add that $1,350,000
to the $1,440,000 of cash
that came in over
those years, you
get $2,790,000 on a
$5,500 investment?
So OK.
I started thinking.
And now I have all the numbers
to figure out what the ROI is.
And just as I was starting
to calculate that,
I thought that's
not right either.
You know why?
Because next month
there's another check.
And the month after that.
It goes on and on, doesn't it?
So what is the ROI on a $5,500
investment that generates
$2.7 million and counting?
I'll tell you what it is.
It's financial freedom.
It is true wealth.
That's what the return
on investment is.
It's true wealth.
And what is true wealth?
True wealth is
financial peace of mind.
It's safe, secure,
dependable cash flow.
It's money you can count
on, month after month,
year after year,
decade after decade.
That, to me, is true wealth.
Let me give you a statistic.
I thought this was
kind of interesting.
60% of Americans feel somewhat
confident about having
enough money to retire.
But only 18% feel
truly confident they
have enough money.
My parents were
part of that 18%.
My family was part of that 18%.
My clients were all
part of that 18%.
Everybody here should
be part of that 18%.
You should have that confidence
that you have enough money
to retire.
Life is full of
choices, isn't it?
And where you decide to
invest your money is a choice,
isn't it?
So, to me, the idea
of investing in
a self-funding, self-sustaining
investment that continues
to grow even during
distributions, as compared
to a continually
diminishing portfolio, well,
there's no question at all.
I mean, the answer's as
simple as, well, this, right?
Pretty easy answer.
[LAUGHTER]
I titled my book
"Destination Perpetuity,"
because the word
perpetuity means
an annuity that has no end,
or a stream of cash that
lasts forever.
That is what real estate
investing can and should be.
Thank you very
much for your time.
[CLAPPING]
If you have some questions,
I'll be here for a few minutes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, let me
throw the mic back to you.
AUDIENCE: Holy cow.
That's awesome.
Never seen the mic.
SPEAKER 1: Google has
the coolest stuff.
AUDIENCE: This is
comfortable to hold too.
Quick question.
Going back to the numbers
you were presenting,
that was really
interesting, but I
struggled to follow where the
mortgage payment, and taxes,
and insurance, and capital
expenditures and all that
was accounted for.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Sure.
So the first 20
years, all of that,
the tenant funding
dollars go in.
They pay off all that.
AUDIENCE: Was it a $4,000
net operating income?
It was your cash flow?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: The
$6,000 and the $4,000?
Yeah.
So that check I was
holding in that bank line?
That's in the pocket.
That's your net.
Yes.
That's after everything
has been paid.
So the mortgage was
already gone at that point.
But that's after the taxes,
the insurance, the property
manager, after money is put
away in a rainy day fund.
Those are your net in the
pocket pre-tax dollars.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So your numbers
started after that 90% debt?
It was 90% leveraged, right?
5% down from your dad.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: So
the first 20 years
the building was paid off.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Your numbers aren't
correlating to that timeframe?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Oh, they didn't?
I have to go back and look.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
I'm wondering.
I was confirming.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
I know.
Those slides, I've
got to clean them up.
They always confuse people.
And it goes too fast too.
So the first 20 years the
building got paid off.
And that's a good rule
of thumb for anybody
investing in real estate.
You should really
try and create a plan
that pays your building
off in 20 years.
I'm looking at some
very young people here.
You pay your building off in
20 years when you're my age,
you have that cash
flow building.
That's sort of the idea of it.
And then the next
20 years you still
have taxes, and insurance,
and all of that.
But because of the
magic of inflation,
those dollars are
always big enough
to then sustain extra cash
flow for the investor.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thank you.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yep.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So obviously
California's super expensive.
If you want to buy anywhere in
LA, It's basically $1 million,
which is a couple
hundred thousand
down for a down payment.
So even if you split it with a
couple people, it's expensive.
What are your thoughts
on buying an investment
property in another state,
even if you're not there
to kind of manage it?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: That's
a great question.
So keep this in mind.
That same argument
you have right there
was what people were
having 40 years ago.
And they'll be having
40 years from now.
So you can buy in other states.
You can buy in other
parts of LA or other parts
of Southern California.
Risk equals reward.
And when I work with
clients, and they
want to buy income
producing property,
I always ask them
the same thing.
I always say, what do you want?
Do you want cash flow, or
do you want to grow equity?
And what do you think
they always say?
Both.
That's what everybody
wants, right?
But you do have to make choices.
In other words, we're
in Venice right now.
So if we go to buy an income
producing property in Venice,
our cap rate's probably going
to be about maybe 2% or 3%.
Right?
It's really bad.
It's going to take
you forever to cash
flow on a property like that.
But what was our appreciation
rate in Venice last year?
It's like 8%.
It's crazy, right?
So now if we take
those same dollars,
and I'll give you
a perfect example.
I have a client that I sold
his property in Redondo Beach.
And he wanted to re-invest
in Southern California.
And the cap rates were not good.
They were like 5% or 6%.
And he said, you know Craig,
I'm going to take my money
and move it to Ohio.
I can get a 9% cap, 10% cap.
That's basically your rate of
return on the money, right.
And I said, OK.
But he was young.
He was 38, 39 years old.
I said, but are you sure
you want to do that?
He said, why?
He said, I have owned
buildings there for years
and they cash flow great.
And I said, how do
they appreciate?
He goes, they don't.
That's where you
make your money.
So you have to create a plan.
You have to say, what do
I really want out of this?
So looking in these, if
everybody here came to me
and said, I want to
invest some dollars,
I'd say appreciation
dollars first, and then
cash flow dollars.
So we have this beautiful thing
called the 1031 tax exchange.
So what I do with clients
when they come to me early
on in their 20s or 30s,
like that, even in your 40s,
my idea of a good plan
would be to invest
someplace that's appreciating.
Don't worry about
the cash flow yet.
Let it appreciate.
Get those appreciation dollars.
Because that's where you make
your real money in real estate.
Then when you have those
appreciation dollars,
you do a 1031 tax
exchange, which
means the IRS allows you
to, not sell that building,
but trade that building
for another property.
So in other words, your
taxes are deferred.
There's no tax dollars
coming out of your pocket
until you would ever sell it.
You take all of that equity.
And you move it into
another property
that has a better cap rate.
I did that with some clients
just a few years ago.
I started working with
them almost 20 years ago.
And we built this beautiful
appreciation portfolio
in the South Bay, Manhattan
Beach, Hermosa Beach,
Redondo Beach.
And they bought all
these properties.
And for 20 years they just
let them grow in appreciation.
Didn't really have
any money coming in
that they could put
in their pocket.
The tenants funded
all the bills.
But then when they were ready
to retire in their late 40s,
we sold everything.
We moved everything
down to Long Beach.
And their cap rate tripled.
And suddenly they had
six figures a year
to retire off of.
So you have to plan it out.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Anybody else?
Yes.
Good shot.
Wow.
AUDIENCE: Not a very
good catch, though.
Do you think there's any value
to flipping houses, buying
houses that are not good,
or buying empty land
and then developing them?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Well, there's two
different questions.
One's developing
and one's flipping.
This is a tough
market for flipping.
You're about eight
years too late.
But we cycle through those
markets all the time.
And there are deals out there.
I just worked with a
developer recently.
A year ago I found him a
property that he could flip.
And we're just working with
counteroffers right now.
But he's a very
shrewd developer.
He knows exactly
what he's doing.
He's got a crew.
And he's going to make a
couple hundred thousand dollars
off it.
But those deals are very
hard to find at the moment.
But we do cycle
through those deals.
Developing is different also.
Developers have to
look at properties.
They have to put on their
own developer glasses
and look two to three
years out, depending
on what you're selling,
what you're trying to build.
And then you have to
guess what the market will
be like when you go to sell it.
What will interest
rates be like?
What will our economy be like?
So, again, seven,
eight years ago
it was easier to see
this steamroller.
Now, I personally think that
we're in a very good economy
right now.
I personally think
our economy is on a--
I think we're going to do
nothing but grow right now.
But with that growth comes
higher interest rates too.
Right?
So it's a double
edged sword, isn't it?
So anybody thinking
about buying,
do it today,
because you're never
going to see these
interest rates again.
So even if you think
prices are too high,
don't worry about
it, because when
you buy real estate, whether
it's income producing
real estate, or real
estate you live in,
what you have to realize is,
you're not buying real estate.
You're buying a payment.
And when you buy a payment
attached to interest rates
like today, it doesn't matter if
the real estate goes like this.
As long as you're buying it with
a 10 year plan, you'll be fine.
So don't ever buy real
estate with short term
plans like flipping, because
that's how you can get burned.
I'm very conservative.
The safest way to
buy real estate--
My theory is never sell
anything, by the way.
But that doesn't mean you
can't trade it, do a 1031,
or something like that.
And I never buy anything with
less than a 10 year plan.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Personally.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
Go.
AUDIENCE: What do you
think about for people
that currently rent?
Should you be prioritizing
buying a place to live in,
or should the investment
idea kind of be
parallel to where you're living?
Because it's hard to save for
a down payment to live, and to
do this investment.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: That's
a good question.
That's a lifestyle question.
It's also a tax question.
I would probably say
to you, buy a place
to live in if you like
where you're going to be.
If you know you're going to
be here at Google for a while,
and you're stable in
your job, and you're
stable in your community,
buy a place to live,
because the tax write offs
for your personal residence
are going to outweigh the tax
write offs for an investment
property.
And what you can do
when you go to sell
that property, or better
yet, trade that property,
you can then move that equity
into an income producing
property if you want.
So you can do that.
But in Venice and
other areas of LA
right now, the average
renter, if you have 20% down,
you can buy and own
for less than you
can rent when you
figure all your tax
savings and your deductions.
So if you're renting
right now and you
can afford to buy, buy it,
because these interest rates,
we'll never see them again.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I have two questions.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The first
one is simpler maybe.
In terms of your
credentials, why don't you
just brag about
your own portfolio
and how this has helped you?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Well, yeah.
I mean, it's great.
I will.
I'll brag about that.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'll also tell
you what I did wrong.
So here's my story.
I started investing when
I was in my early 20s.
And by the time I got to
44 or so, I was retired.
I was done.
I had all the positive cash
flow I needed to retire.
And then I started
seeing these investments
that looked really good.
A little bit too good maybe?
And one by one I started selling
properties off and investing
in these other investments.
It turned out to
be a Ponzi scheme.
I lost almost everything.
And by the time I was
50 I had to start over.
58, next month, right
back where I needed to be.
I had great focus,
and it was my career,
so it was not hard for me to do.
I did have a little
bit of real estate
that I was able to play
with and move things around.
And I knew how to watch the
market and see where to go.
But I've done it twice.
It works.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And then the second question
is, is your advice to people--
and maybe you already
answered this, so forgive me,
but is your advice to people
who don't have that much cash
to partner with other people?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
I talk about that in my book.
Talk about double
edged swords again.
They're good and they're bad.
You have to really be
careful who you partner with.
And even if it's your
best friend, or a sibling,
or whatever, get
everything in writing.
And most importantly, get a
good exit strategy in writing.
Because invariably, if you
two guys partner on something,
one of you is going to want
out before the other one.
And it's going to be a problem.
So you have to create
an exit strategy.
You have to do all that.
But it is one of the best
ways to own real estate.
And I've owned I don't even know
how many pieces of property.
And I've owned dozens and dozens
of properties in partnerships.
And just you have to be
careful who you partner with.
And you have to be very
clear on who's doing what,
and how you're getting out.
And then partnerships are fine.
Yeah.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I bought
management companies.
I've heard stories, good
stories and bad stories.
Like oh, we'll take
away all your headache.
And then some of it
is like, oh my god,
if I've done it myself it
would have been better,
save me way more money.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Any?
It's management-- [SIGHS] Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because if you
have so many properties
you're going to have
management for sure.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: I know.
AUDIENCE: Do it yourself.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: So we have seven
properties, my family and I.
And we have some we
manage ourselves, some
we have property managers for.
It's like anything else.
It's hard to find good
property managers.
So if you're going to invest in
income producing real estate,
I would almost find a good
property manager first.
And the best way to do
that is talk to people
that you know that own
income producing real estate.
Ask them who they use.
Get references.
Get referrals.
Go online.
Check everybody out.
There's some really
good people out there.
And you shouldn't have to
pay more than about 5% or 6%
for a really good
property manager.
And I will tell you this, if
you get a good property manager,
they'll actually
make you more money.
Because what they
do is they are going
to keep your units filled.
They're going to keep them
filled at market rent.
If there's a problem, they're
going to take care of it,
not you.
So property management
is the way to go.
But you have to be very careful
who you choose as your property
manager.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
to hear how the new tax
laws are affecting 1031
exchanges and write offs.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Well, there's no
effect with 1031s.
But write offs,
depreciation is a big deal.
That's a big, big deal.
So what's happening is that
your primary residence is now
capped at $800,000.
So that's going to be a game
changer for real estate.
Now, I live in Redondo Beach.
So our neighboring community
is Manhattan Beach.
And the joke there is everybody
lives in a McMansion, right?
They're these giant houses,
3,500, 4,000 square feet.
The yard's about as
big as this stage.
And everybody moved
in there 25 years ago.
And they were really popular.
And everybody paid like $1
million or $2 million for them.
Well, now they're worth about
$2.5 million in today's market,
right?
But my crystal ball says, people
aren't going to want those.
Because, first of all, they're
all filled with empty nesters.
They don't want to go up and
down those stairs anymore.
And the house is too big.
They're going to
try and sell them.
And guess what.
If I'm going to buy a house, I'm
not going to buy a $2.5 million
giant box that I
can only write off
maybe a third of my interest.
So that portion of the market
is really going to be impacted.
Now, I would say that the
$1.4 million and less market--
good luck finding something
like that anywhere around here--
but that market's
going to be very solid.
So the real estate community
is going to change.
And, as all of that's going
on with these new tax laws,
mark my words, interest
rates are going up this year
big time.
So with the new
incoming Fed chief,
you're probably going to see at
least three raises this year,
if not more.
And I think they'll
be significant.
They're not going to
be Janet Yellen raises.
They're going to be real raises.
So we're going to be
in a shifting economy.
So if I was planning
on buying something,
what would I buy today?
I'd try and probably look
for a primary residence.
If I didn't have
only 20% to put down,
I'd probably look for something
at $1.4 million, $1.3 million,
something like that to maximize
as much of that $800,000 as I
could.
But I'd get in the interest
rate game right now.
Because that's going to change.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering, if you
were to choose an
investment, would you
prefer, assuming they
are the same price
range, single family,
versus multi unit,
versus a condo in a complex?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Great question.
And I'll take those in
order of what I believe
to be the least desirable.
And that's the condo.
Condo is least desirable because
when markets shift they always
get hurt the worst.
You have the least
control over a condo,
and the least control
of your finances
because you also have
an association that's
controlling how much you have
to spend every single month.
And the desirability
of resale is
much less than a single family.
So condos are the
least desirable.
Single family is in the middle.
Single family is great.
Always going to have a
single family market.
People love those.
They always appreciate
really well.
But the multi-family will do
better as an investment always.
Why?
It's because what we
call the number of doors.
So doors refers to how
many tenants you have.
So if you have a single
family home over here,
and you have a three
unit building over here,
and you have a vacancy over
here, you got a 100% vacancy.
If you got a vacancy over
here, you have a 1/3 vacancy.
And everything, your
costs always get so much--
the words are escaping me here.
There's a cost benefit basically
to having multiple units.
And you'll always,
always do better.
Investors look for as
many doors as they can.
So somebody who's
really a big time
investor in the multi-family,
they want a huge complex.
They want as many
doors as they can,
because that's
really where you make
your money is the
number of doors,
the number of tenants you have.
And that's the safest
way to go as well.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I was
wondering if you
had any thoughts on commercial
versus residential real estate,
and basically if there's
different strategies that you
need to take with each?
And what are the things
to caution about?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Sure.
Risk equals reward.
And it's interesting.
I own commercial properties.
And we also own residential
income producing properties.
The commercial properties,
a few years ago
when the economy melted
down, what happened?
What happened?
The stock market failed.
Real estate prices plummeted,
and businesses shuttered down,
right?
So there went your
commercial real estate.
What happened to multi-family?
Bulletproof.
As a matter of fact, so many
people lost their homes,
there was such a big pool
of renters, prices went up.
When was the last time you
heard rents are going down?
It just doesn't happen.
Residential income producing
real estate, in my book
I talk about it being
recession resilient.
I wanted to put recession
proof, but my publisher
said I couldn't do that.
I'd get sued.
But recession resilient.
I believe it's recession proof
if you buy in the right area.
When was the last time you
heard rents are going down?
It doesn't happen.
But with commercial, it does.
Commercial goes through that.
Plus with commercial, like I
own a couple of warehouses.
And both of them I've
split into two pieces.
They were single, but I
put two tenants in there
just to mitigate in
case one moves out.
But I've had both of
those dark at times.
Now, I get a much better rate of
return, a much better cap rate,
if you will, off of my
commercial properties.
But I don't lose any sleep
off my residential income
properties, especially if I
have a good property manager.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: For someone who
wants to get into or add
real estate as part
of their portfolio,
but does not want to do
anything with buying,
management property,
et cetera, is there
an easy way where I can
just give my cash to someone
and get some of a return?
I mean, there's REITs,
but peer to peer stuff.
Do you have a
recommendation for someone?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Give it to me.
I'll take care of it.
No.
REITs are fine.
But keep in mind,
when you own REITs,
you don't own real estate.
You own stock.
That's different.
So there are groups
that do that.
And, again, it's kind of
like the property management
question.
It's like, who are you
giving your money to?
I've just seen too many
people hurt on those.
Personally I think if you're
going to be a real estate
investor, and there
is work to it,
and there's work the
entire time you own it,
I think you have to be hands
on, or probably then just buy
a single family home.
And that is your
real estate nest egg.
AUDIENCE: Actually my question
was exactly why not just
buy like that fund in our 401k?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Exactly.
That's stocks.
That's REITs.
But you don't have as
much control over that.
And you have a different
set of write offs.
So you can certainly invest
in real estate that way.
But when you invest with
a portfolio like that,
somebody else is making
those bigger choices for you.
You're deciding when to buy
and when to sell, right?
But what is invested
in is different.
And there's a cost to that.
Because those people that run
the REITs are getting paid.
So there's a large
amount of what
could be your profit
that's going to them.
So if you make those
choices yourself,
you're gaining all
that profit yourself.
It's just a different
theory of investing.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any tips
for market research
except looking at cap rates?
Like other things that
you would look at?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: My tip is
get a good real estate agent.
Seriously.
I mean, that's my
best tip is find
somebody who's a professional
in the area you want to look at.
AUDIENCE: No.
I mean, like research for areas.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Oh,
research for areas.
You know, that's
a good question.
And that's a fluid question
too, because areas are always
gentrifying.
Like right now everybody's
excited about Inglewood.
The stadium's going in there.
What's going to
happen with Inglewood.
And people are excited
about Hawthorne too.
Is SpaceX going to buy the
Toyota space and move in there?
So there's all these sort
of fluid things going on.
Right now in Southern California
we're in such a good market
I think that you're fine
almost wherever you go.
But look at anybody
that bought real estate
15 years ago in Venice.
My gosh, right?
Just unbelievable.
So you see something
happening like Google
moving into a neighborhood,
put money there.
There's all kinds
of things like that.
So you have to watch
for the opportunities.
And you just have to
be cognizant of what's
going on around you.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
So basically if you
have two options,
one is a really nice house
on a smaller piece of land,
versus a crappy house on
a large piece of land.
So if you wanted to
choose between the two,
what is the trade off?
CRAIG O'ROURKE:
Buy the crappy one.
Always.
You always want to buy the worst
house in the best neighborhood.
Location, location, location.
Those are truly the three
rules of real estate.
And if you're a handy guy,
and you can get in there
and fix it yourself,
or you have the money,
that's a great opportunity.
Because that property,
if somebody's selling it
in a condition like that
where it's falling apart,
it's been priced
accordingly, or you're
going to pay for it accordingly.
And then you create
what you want it to be.
You go in, and you decide
what floors you want,
and countertops, and all that.
You make it your own, especially
if you're going to live there.
And even if you're going to rent
it out, you do the same thing.
But you'll always
want to buy, if you
have the time, and the
energy, and the willpower
to go through all that.
Because it's a lot.
But it's like with
somebody else asked
about property management.
Real estate you'll
always be involved
in maintaining
that to some level,
even if you have
property managers.
So if you're not scared
of that, if you're not
scared of taking that property
and making it something better,
that's the opportunity.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this might
be an open ended question
on your advice for
looking for tenants if I
don't have a management firm.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Like how
long the contract
is, and what do you look for in
a tenant if you're doing that?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: The first thing
you do is run a credit report.
And what I always do,
I run a credit report,
and I tell my prospective
tenant, here's a credit report.
You pay for it.
If you have A plus credit,
I'll rent the place to you
and pay for your credit report.
But if your credit's bad,
and I give him a break point,
then you're paying
for the credit report
and I'm not renting it to you.
And what happens then is most
people who have bad credit
don't even run
the credit report.
They just go away on their own.
So once you get the credit
report, that's really
what you're looking at, because
people that have good credit,
they got there by
paying their bills.
And that's really what
you're looking for.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So if you were to
be looking at an investment
property, like let's
say a fourplex,
and you're OK with it maybe
being like a long term
investment, like 10
years plus, you're
going to kind of be more focused
on the long term appreciation
and keeping hold
of it, what would
be a sort of minimum
cap rate that you
would recommend purchasing at?
And also do you want
something that perhaps needs
a little bit of work,
so as tenants move out
you can kind of come in and do
a little bit of cosmetic fixing?
Do you want something that you
don't have to do anything to?
Not even like cosmetic
that has no vacancies,
and has a really low turnover?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: You
have a lot of questions.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Sorry.
CRAIG O'ROURKE:
That's all right.
AUDIENCE: That was
like five questions.
CRAIG O'ROURKE: I
think I got them all.
OK.
So let's start
with the cap rate,
because that's really important.
Cap rates are area specific.
And they're also
property specific.
So like we said earlier,
cap rate here in Venice
is probably about 2 and 1/2%,
3%, something like that.
Cap rate down in Long
Beach is about 6 and 1/2%.
So, again, I would say,
what is your motivation?
Are you buying for appreciation
or are you buying for cash
flow?
If you say I want
both, then I'm going
to find an area with
about 5% cap rate.
So that's the cap rate thing.
There's no right cap
rate or a wrong cap rate.
There's a right cap
rate and a wrong cap
rate for a specific area.
And also for a
specific property too.
Because even if
you're in Long Beach,
and you have one property
that has an ocean
view and another one that's
next to a smelting factory,
they look exactly
the same, they're
going to have different
cap rates because they're
different desirabilities.
So those questions are
always very specific.
Each property is so specific.
But right now, in general,
most of my investors
are looking for a 5% cap.
And that's not
that easy to find.
And so that's sort
of the hard part
is finding that middle
of the road property.
And that's where most
investor dollars are going.
Your other question.
Remind me?
AUDIENCE: It was, do you want to
buy something that maybe needs
a little bit of
light cosmetic work,
so that as a tenant moves
out you can do a little work
and increase the rents?
CRAIG O'ROURKE: Yeah.
Again, risk equals reward.
If you don't mind
doing that, you'll
get a property
that probably will
be on the market for a
little bit less money.
And when they move
out, as long as you
have sort of that
slush fund going,
and you're willing to
spend those dollars.
Because when they
move out you will
need to spend those dollars.
You will need to paint.
You will need to carpet.
You will need to bring it
up to whatever the level is
of that rental market.
So you have to really keep
those dollars on hand.
And depending on
what the property is,
depending on the
value of the property,
it's healthy to keep a pretty
handy slush fund around,
because you never know.
If all of a sudden three or
four people go dark at once
in a 10 unit building, that's
a lot of money going away.
So you have to be prepared.
Not only do you have to keep
your mortgage going, right?
Your taxes, your
insurance, all that.
But now you've got to
rehab all these units.
It usually doesn't
happen like that.
Usually people move
out one at a time.
Usually they're
giving you notice.
Usually it's lot more smooth.
But you never know.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]